I was on American Idol this past season
I did um
well I told them straight up in order
for me to be my most optimal self I'll
need some of these accommodations I was
the only non-minor there who had his mom
with him during that time and I'm proud
to admit that I'm a mama's
boy hi I'm gen and I explore issues
through both sides and I'll be
moderating this Middle Ground episode of
autistic and neurotypical and the first
prompt is I find the word disabled
offensive can the agers please step
forward I think you should go back there
okay well I guess I'll start off first
um so being on the Spectrum the autism
spectrum myself and being someone who
masks my autism pretty well I have a
hard time accepting the fact that
technically yes I am disabled because
throughout my
entire life I've had to deal with things
like sensory overload you know dealing
with high emotions at times and stuff
like that but I also was raised to be a
go-getter and to if I put my mind to
anything I can accomplish my goals and
so and I have accomplished stuff I'm a
writer I've written about being on the
Spectrum for Insider the de and places
like that and I don't let my disability
stop me so it's like you know we live in
this world where having a disability is
a bad thing and I and most people kind
of operate that way and like view
disabled people in a negative light and
so for me whenever someone calls me
disabled it's definitely a trigger for
me to be honest yeah I would agree with
exactly what you're saying that was kind
of why the reason I came up as well um I
feel that as a root it's not an
offensive word but the stigma that our
society has made it today has created it
to be an offensive word my my son is
non-verbal he's never said a word never
had anything um use communication with
his language what I find the problem
with disabled uh that I've always had an
issue with is it looks at my son in a
way where he's supposed to be fitting
into everyone else's world even movies
that are made about autism that are
supposed to be like these movies that
are make everybody love autism usually
at the end of the movie they do
something in everyone else's world that
makes them special they catch a
touchdown they they go to prom my son's
not going to catch a touchdown my son's
not going to go to prom he doesn't care
about those things and sometimes you can
just be who you are and you don't have
to be labeled well you don't do these
things so you're disable
can it disagree or please step forward
please I never read too deeply into the
word disabled it's just a descriptor of
me I'm disabled no one's really used
disabled as an insult to me at least not
in any way that I've been able to pick
up on it however people have used the RW
to me and that is what is offensive to
me uh disabled is just a descriptor at
the same time though I feel like this is
a real test for the great area here
because I still somehow agree with what
every single one of you just said even
though I disagree with the prompt but
everybody has their own relationship
with words and terminology and I think
that that's what's so beautiful about
the autism Community I uh find myself
agreeing with what James is saying where
you know his son probably shouldn't have
to conform to the ideas that the world
is uh setting in place like maybe he's
perfectly happy uh being non-verbal and
he shouldn't be expected to talk um but
at the same time if we try and say you
know disabilities don't exist and that
everyone has to fit in this box right
and we get rid of the term all together
then that's kind of maybe forcing people
like James's son to uh conform to the
world just to piggy back off of that say
James uh have you told your son about
this episode and has your son ever Comm
uh communicated uh any degree of
advocacy to you at all I talk to him
about everything people always tell me
when they find out he's non-verbal
they're like you should talk to him I'm
like I talk to him more than I talk to
anybody else on earth like it's constant
there's things he doesn't understand
like fundamental things that he doesn't
understand he doesn't understand that
I'm going to do this he doesn't
understand what autism is he doesn't
understand things like that but I tell
him I'm like we're going to go we're
going to talk about you we're going to
have you know all the great things about
you when I relate to my son what I try
to do is I try to put myself in his
shoes so I write a blog about him I try
to do autism appreciation I call it
where I talk about the positives of
autism and how he's a great kid not
despite autism but in many ways because
of autism that makes me very happy to
hear I'd love to read your blog thank
you Jubilee viewers you should read his
blog man my new hype man thank you so
back to the prompt just like what you
have said I was one of the few people
that fac the r word especially in high
school I haven't been called disabled
for for any reason to be offensive for
me anyways but I do see like how it can
be debatable and questionable because it
can come off as like you're trying to
say this person can't do something just
because they
can't think accordingly or maybe cannot
walk accordingly or can't concentrate
accordingly do you identify or view
yourself as
disabled ye yes but I don't I don't
personally find it offensive for me
because I feel like there's just uglier
words but I do respect what everyone
else is coming from though what do you
think of that word disabled does it
bother you disabled um for me the kind
of autism I have is a communication
disorder like for example when I was a
little girl I walked around in circles
talking to myself I wanted to join the
conversation but I didn't know how and
my brain wouldn't do what I was telling
it to do and I've had 20 years of speech
therapy 15 years of Occupational Therapy
to be able to talk like everyone else to
get where I am today so you think it's
okay to use the word disability because
it helps people understand how hard
you've worked to be in the conversation
I'm even in the therapy right now that's
true and I would agree with Abby on that
I would say that because this um autism
word and Spectrum now has successful
people and writers who are neurod
different and people who have had 22 20
years of speech therapy and I'm one of
them you are and and Rockstar over here
but but it's conf conf using so I I like
the word disability because when we're
in public and Abby has a stem or arms
are fling you know yeah and some people
in the Spectrum tend to rock back and
forth and flop their hands and that's a
stem why you got to call me that out I
was doing that just now no literally
I've been holding my hands like this do
thing I even do this or I um but I don't
rock back and forth right but that's not
your stem but other people do like that
so but whatever that thing is I just
feel like if you understand that autism
can be different can be a disability
because I don't have to stem I can stem
this is a stem too but it's not
imperative for me to do that to be in
this conversation right now I do have a
question though because the r word kind
of came up amongst few of few of you
guys is there any Nuance with that in
that being not offensive or offensive no
just straight up no because the thing is
we've come such a long way in terms of
like well I don't know if long way in
terms of understanding autism I think
that's why we're all here but but um
just more like like we've gone past that
word and I remember there was I used to
work at a coffee shop and there was this
guy who would never call people that
word but he just would say like oh
that's th word like that's that like
whatever he was kind of like one of
those people that was kind of like well
it's just a word and it's just a word
I'm like well there are several other
English words to use so it's just like I
don't really see the like the medical in
field has gotten past it we should get
past it the year is not 1940 and at this
point in today's modern language it is
really an insult um especially going to
public high school I hear that a lot
yeah I have trouble making friends can
the agers step
up I get emotional thinking about this
um I still am struggling especially now
um it just feels like everyone
is you
know I never had any friends until third
grade I only talked about Pokemon with
him and that was it and he was probably
likely also on the Spectrum and I was so
severely bullied at my public elementary
school girls tended to be nicer to me uh
as opposed to boys um I see eye to eye
yeah I have a lot of trauma that I'm
working through um regarding bullying in
that way I find it harder to talk to men
even today for that reason I I I'm
lonely I'm I'm so
lonely I I really I I Channel all of it
into my music I Channel every aspect of
my loneliness and trying to understand
other people and trying to connect with
other people in my music and my
songwriting uh it is my coping mechanism
and uh I just try and keep myself busy
uh
to uh cope with the fact that I really
really struggled to make friends um when
I was a little girl life was very very
hard I didn't have any friends I
couldn't I wanted to join the
conversation but I couldn't because my
bra wouldn't do what I was telling him
to do and for in high school I sat alone
at lunch and I had didn't really have
any friends until I didn't start making
friends till I was like 17 or 18
somewhere around there and truly
because I've all that's why I've always
wanted to be an adult because I knew I'd
have more language it'll be easy for me
to communicate and life would be life in
general would would have been easier I
actually can relate with Aiden to an
extent I I had a difficult time making
friends because well at the time when I
was younger of course I didn't know I
had autism but I was also a little bit
different I was those autistic kids who
kind of was a social bu fly at the time
so believe it or not aside from how I
appear I was such an extrovert I was
being seen in middle school as kind of
like a Class Clown and in by like high
school the first high school I went to
which was a really bad school I was put
the little the gay stigma because of my
voice because all the guys there their
voices are more like low like this but
mine but at the time iine was like more
higher like this but it was hard in by
the other high school which I spent the
rest of my high school years I made a
little bitty friends but people who
actually did not just disregard me and
did not see me as like a walking joke or
some potential loss caused cuz a lot of
them was weirdly enough afraid of me of
what I can do so well I would like to
chime in in case it were to okay never
mind in a in a sec um yeah well now I
don't
remember well no I do um I have friends
I do have friends but I only have
friends one at a time I have never in my
life ever truly been a part of a friend
group and and I have some of the most
beautiful friendships ever and they're
so quality because it's just me and that
one friend but man I just I just wish I
could be a part of a group I was out in
public recently I saw four artsy looking
people people that were about my age and
they were all talking and having a blast
and I was just looking at them just
like the jealousy kicks in yeah when am
I going to have that that's what I
wanted to add you can move on now it's
funny cuz I disagreed I was the only one
on my side who disagreed but I also can
pinpoint each and like each of you in
something that you said because I
definitely can relate I think I've
Gotten Good at developing surface level
friendships as an adult I still don't
really know how to find that line
between like opening myself up but
also not expecting the same in return
from the other person CU sometimes they
don't know how to give the same in
return so it's just like it's not just
necessarily like that the other person
has bad intentions it's just the way we
communicate and the way that we think
can be different and just not always
work and I think that's still something
I'm struggling with even here like
hearing you guys over there when I was
disagreeing the level of openness that
you're willing to share these stories is
like it's what we always say we want
like as a parent you go I want to have a
I want to have a kid who's who's you
know honest and who doesn't lie and who
doesn't do these things and then I'm
like he has Au like a I'm like no but
that's exactly what we all want right we
want thing and they don't get it and
I've I've struggled with my son my son
is not I mean Socia was always in my
opinion like out the window for him he's
not very like he doesn't want to
socialize hang out with people but what
ended up happening was my girlfriend's
son is is minimally verbal and he's
known him since he was like 3 years old
and whenever we would get together he
would always like try to play with my
son and and Lucas was just kind of like
whatever and we noticed about a year ago
they were in the pool and like Lucas
started like following him around the
pool trying to like tag him I was like
oh my God is this happening and we've
noticed slowly that he's been doing that
too I see that I I worried about him
having you know people be his friend I
worry about people taking advantage of
him I worry about neurotypical people
sometimes having the worst in intentions
these people who who don't have
disabilities are the ones who sometimes
do some of the
cruestv helping friendships it's ironic
cuz I'm insanely social like I traveled
Europe by myself with a backpack and I'm
still friendly with people I met for a
week on a train in Venice when Abby was
um as she told you a little kid she
almost didn't see them it's like I
didn't see them like other kids she just
walked right past them she was so in her
own world which is her kind of autism
and can I explain the whole Ariel story
um you can sure and when I was a really
little kid when I first saw the move we
Walt Disney's The Little Mermaid I
really understood Ariel and she she
inspired me Ariel was my inspiration
because it's just like how where she
wanted to be with the humans and I
wanted to be with the neurotypical
people just like that and when Ariel
became human she couldn't talk that's
how I felt that's exct exactly the kind
of autism I have too Abby really yeah
except I never verbalized it like you
did I have looked out on someone for
being
autistic I'll sit next to you why
not um yeah I mean I have I mean I'm not
proud of it cuz I was diagnosed around
three or four years old and my parents
got me intervention very early because
of that I was able to get coping skills
and learn how to mask and learn how
to essentially be like everyone else I'm
at a weird Point like the last couple
years I've really have come to realize
that like the mask I've had to put on
has really been kind of like cemented
onto my face and like my autistic self
is like something I'm still trying to
chip away at like when I was younger
like I was never the one to bully anyone
but like I would take note of like other
kids who I felt like were autistic like
whether they stemmed noticeably or not
and I kind of subconsciously would just
sort of be like well I can mask why
can't you keep it together for for lack
of a better way of saying it and I'm
certainly not proud of it and it's
something that I definitely am working
towards correcting about myself but for
me to say that I haven't done that would
be a lie which is why which is why I'm
sitting
here I never really spoke or never
looked down on those on the Spectrum and
this was obviously before I found out I
so I'll just because I was diagnosed at
2 and then I later found up by like I
think middle school year but I
never looked down on them because in the
end of the day for me anyways they're
human and let alone aside from me being
autistic I'm also can be looked down
because I'm as you all see I'm
alternative and stuff so there's just no
point for me anyways to look down on
someone that's on a spectrum or anyone
who is who's with special needs or has
any other disabilities that they may not
have asked for anyways from the
information I've gathered the four of us
who were on the Spectrum were all
diagnosed very early I would be very
very curious to know uh somebody
somebody who has diagnosed much later's
perspective on that especially since for
so many of these later diagnosed people
they don't realize they're on the
Spectrum immediately I've sat at parties
with asger kids which I know you're not
supposed to say that word but the
intelligence in an Asperger person is
such a gift H and I learned all about
astronomy from this one kid in two hours
and his mother was saying oh leave her
leave the nice lady alone and I was like
no please let him stay with me this is
so cool so that's because I'm coming
from that place of looking at
neurodiversity autism Asbergers in in a
different way because I've been around
it for 25 years I'm a teacher's aid for
the beginning theater class at my school
and there are a quite a few kids in the
class with autism sometimes they'll say
something that's a little crazy or a
little out there some like some other
kid might take offense to it but I just
know like sometimes there's no filter
like it's okay and I'm just like okay
like let's talk about why that might not
work why that not might not be a thing
to say or if it's something that's like
whatever we can just move past it so
yeah definitely like no judgment at all
like I understand that sometimes s
there's like less of a filter or
something else like that so both of my
parents are special education Preschool
teachers um they've bounced around
throughout the grade levels but when I
was in preschool I went to the same
campus that they did and I was in a
class where myself and then later my
sister were the only two neurotypical
kids um everyone else there either had
autism Aspergers or some sort of
physical disability it's not something
where I would look down on a person for
having that just because I've been
around it so long but I know that um
like we were talking about public high
schools and kids in general can be
really cruel and it's not uncommon to
see uh autism or the RW being thrown
around as an insult it happens on social
media all the time especially Tik Tok un
Tik Tok is like a war ground a battle
ground for like the rudest meanest most
judgmental people and sadly a percentage
of them say they are on the Spectrum
prior to my son being diagnosed I
remember one of the things that worried
me was that as a parent when you first
have a baby autism is almost treated
like something you have to avoid like it
was it's almost like be careful don't
like don't feed him this don't do this
don't tell him that and then when he had
autism I was like okay now what and they
were all like and I'm like but what is
what does it mean nobody can tell me
what it meant nobody tell me what it
looked like he smiles he hugs me they're
like some people hug is he going to talk
maybe I'm like you're not going to tell
me anything what am I going to find out
about him so I was preconditioned to be
fearful of this thing that once I saw
saw how it affected Our Lives personally
it wasn't bad you know it was one of
those things where like I was expecting
the worst possible situation I think a
lot of times people have opinions on
something that they don't know anything
about what I actually just realized is
one of the key defining moments was
actually like remembering I was having a
hard time socializing in middle school I
remember I remember one commercial yeah
me too from Autism Speaks it was like
the black plague was Among Us and just
talking about an Autism it's like autism
was basically treated like this curse
and you know it's going to creep on you
when you're least expecting it and
everything like and I remember that
commercial vividly and it's just like
what kind of message are you sending out
to the whole world who does who won't
take the time to educate themselves on
things and I'm so happy that Autism
Speaks has really stepped up their game
in recent years since then it's harder
for autistic people to get a job join a
middleground patreon to watch this
exclusive
prompt
accommodations should be made for
autistic people to be included in
society something that I've written
about quite a bit and why I felt like
I've had to write about my autistic
experiences a lot as an adult is because
there are no Services really for adults
and I that's a problem at least like
besides like the speech therapies and
stuff like that I mean in terms of like
for me learning how to be social it was
something I had to learn on my own and
like I know that other autistic people
unfortunately will struggle with
substance abuse and alcoholism and stuff
like that because you know putting on
the mask can be so exhausting and you
just kind of like don't know what else
to do taking THC for me has helped
really kind of learn helped me learn how
to about my autism actually which is
sounds like such a stoner thing I don't
consider myself a stoner but just you
know I don't think those are concrete
things like you know and I I do think
think that the medical industry in part
by updating their understanding and
updating terminology I do think that
there needs to be more what are some
specific accommodations you would like
to see I don't know if I can think of
specific accommodations but I think just
again just like this overall
misunderstanding of autism really as
cliche as it is I mean it really just
affects every single autistic person
well the problem is that autism
manifests itself in so many unique ways
and it can differ so much from person to
person that you know the moment that
you're out of the public school system
right uh they stop providing an aid
right and exactly yeah navigating life
yourself like that is probably really
difficult um it's difficult for a
typical person coming out of high school
in this day and age with the pressures
and social media in your face I see it
with her brother it is so hard I think
for a lot of people let alone someone
and then the parents of the person who
just turned 18 trying to help their kid
build a life yeah with no support no
support it's it takes a lot of fight I'm
a fighter so I speak from that I've been
there done that I have C cried more
hours on the phone trying to get
accommodations and programs going for
her after 18 than I did when she was a
younger kid not to mention colleges are
one of the few places that has a piss
poor reputation I'm not saying all
universities and colleges but most of
them has a piss Port reputation for not
having appropriate accommodations but
not just for for for kidss on specium
but I mean other kids whether they're
neurotypical but they are have special
education they could be over stimulating
yeah they can be over stimulating
because when you're out of high school
and you're trying to figure out what you
want to do especially with college and
and you try to get me ip it I mean sorry
IEP it feels like you're going under
because I'm trying so hard to scream I
need assistance but it's like they still
won't hear me I'm in a new College I'm
going to be tending down soon but the
other one that I finished my A8 in they
made a a big reputation for not taking
appropriate matters when dealing with
people with IEPs or that really does
need help even if they're not on the
Spectrum congrats on your AA let's hear
from the
disagree all right just to be clear I do
not disagree with any of
you but I do disagree with the prompt
because obviously people on the Spectrum
need accommodations I had an IEP growing
like I accommodations all the time but I
really am hopeful that we can get to a
where we won't uh need accommodations to
be included in
society you know what I mean like I like
we should like for example best buddies
an
organization they they say it firsthand
they exist to not exist they're doing
these amazing services for including
disabled people but ultimately the goal
is for that to not happen MH I always
try to be respectful of everybody else
like if we are at a loud restaurant and
he's yelling at a loud restaurant
everyone's yelling you can yell at a li
if we're at a library if we're at
recital or something I take him outside
so because of that there's things we
can't do but in the last few years we've
been going to like on Broadway they'll
have autism friendly presentations we
saw the rock hats we saw the Nutcracker
and it was so great to not only be able
to do that with him and let him be able
to see that and be a part of it and to
not stand out out but on top of it too
people who are affected by autism
differently than my son to see them
given like you know fidget toys and they
squee I'm like this is such a a
beautiful thing and I think sometimes
when we talk about accommodations a lot
of people who are neurotypical see it as
okay what are you going to do to my
thing now to make it easier for somebody
else and what I'm saying is you don't
necessarily have to change what you're
doing but maybe make something that my
son can go to as well where if he's not
going to interfere with what you're
doing that kind of a thing that's how I
saw it when I when I sat down for it
just the because you were talking about
Broadway shows I know the show how to
dance in Ohio which is I saw it I love
how saw how to dance in Ohio I was great
um but I think if I remember correctly I
think they do have like a sensory room
they do they have a sensory room they
have spinners they have all kinds of
stuff that's accommodated and the
performers are on the spectacle right
and so like with that I think we can
normalize things like that I was on
American Idol this past season I did um
well and I I told them straight up um in
order for me to be my most optimal self
in or and in order for me to be my best
self I'll need some of these
accommodations I'll need you I
understand that you know schedules are a
bit loose when it comes to you know
entertainment industry related stuff but
if you can just give me some degree of a
little push you know as to giving me
some sort of ETA for this that and the
other and they were great they were
great I had a wonderful experience on
American Idol for that reason I was the
only non-minor there who had his mom
with him during that time um and I'm
proud to admit that I'm a mama's
boy autistic people are not accurately
represented in the
[Music]
media Let's go
people I have so many thoughts about
this it's okay obviously I'm a white
autistic male and a lot of like the
mainstream representation are quote
unquote like super intelligent white
autistic na s but that's all there
really is and for me I'm not like Shan
on the good doctor I think we've
definitely made some good progress with
certain things but I just remember
growing up it was always like
superficial stereotype and I just would
love to see autism represented in a way
that's more nuanced with like
particularly with women like not all
autistic women are Temple grandon and as
brilliant as she is as brilliant as she
is but that's not that the problem is
they want to take these
like pillars and just kind of think that
like these are the only options it's
either like the worst of the worst or
the best of the best and that's not fair
and it's not true that's so true you
know I want to see an autistic character
where their autism isn't necessarily
like their whole story I have some
friends who think that and I think this
is probably kind of prevalent if you say
they have autism they're either they
have Savant syndrome right where they're
just a genius and they can magically uh
do something perfectly like play piano
um or they're a person who has really
low functioning autism and you know they
can't do much you know they need able
people to help them it's unfortunate
that that's kind of the two stories that
are being pushed um and there's not a
lot of nuance there and people assume uh
the worst or the best and they don't
look at it the other way so my thing is
I wish that this the term Spectrum keeps
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
it what it doesn't do is honor the
individual skill sets like you have an
incredible skill set you just got your
AA congratulations you know and and your
son sounds amazing and loving and sweet
and you know what that is because you
spend all your time with them and and
this charm right here is amazing but but
what bothers me the most is that in the
media like Tik Tok for example I guess
it's trending to be autistic and I'm
very worried about this it's trending
magic Thomas well what I'd like to say
is if you have sensory issues you're now
called autistic I grew up with a brother
who had sensory issues he is not
autistic but now you're clumped in with
that so then what is the representation
if there's literally not three levels
but 50 levels of functioning 50 levels
of functioning yeah it's confusing on
Tik Tok you'll see like someone with
eight million followers on Tik Tok who's
a comedian who's the funniest person
ever and who's I'm an amazing fan of is
is looking for an Autism diagnosis at 35
with a college degree and two kids and
you go oh I want wonder what that is for
them because did you have any speech
therapy what is it and why do you feel
you need that diagnosis but that media
attention is what's is what's permeating
the rest of people who are not familiar
with autism thinking oh I have I don't
like loud noises I hate the sun I must
too be autistic and that's a that's a
worry for me I'm I'm curious do you
think that media representation could
you see it like in a positive light in
the sense that now people are wanting to
identify with it because they've seen
the positive traits of autism I I don't
there's something positive going on with
it being I use the word trendy but I
will tell you if I didn't have people
that attack me on social media for
helping Abby to get her what do we say
what's our sentence to get your brain do
what I'm telling it to do of course
right to get her brain to do what she's
telling it haters I know there's some
really mean people and it's because I'm
helping the haters are ugly and the
haters were extremely
overweight that's quite an insult now
why don't you tell them why is that you
said that because you're thinking in
categories because I think in categories
this is the way my mind works and I
wrote a song about it right so that's
but that is part of what we're dealing
with to be in the conversation right
here right now in media there's the
gender stereotypes there's the racial
stereotypes and people are saying oh we
need to fight the stereotypes but
everyone's okay with the stereotypes
about autism happening and there
obviously is a small group of people
trying to fight those but there's not as
big of a realm of oh we need to fight
the racial stereotypes ifight the gender
stereotypes as there is for the
rest okay once again I totally agree
with everybody um but the reason why I
stayed back is because I can't lie here
I really do feel like I have been
represented quite well but I think the
reason for that is thees I am the
stereo I'm I'm a I'm a you know blonde
boy I was diagnosed as a child I you
know I was in my own world I I was I was
in my own world too yeah I was
considered you know gifted with my you
know piano skills and Perfect Pitch as a
child a lot of people called me a
prodigy as a child so I fit that
stereotype another reason why I stayed
back is because I think we're headed in
a better direction for example how to
dance in Ohio um there's a another
series I watched just recently was a a
British series heartbreak High the
character I mentioned earlier yeah yeah
no there there there are some great
stuff out there uh my personal favorite
Disney Pixar's loop I think you I think
you would really enjoy it because it
features a non-speaking character and
it's played by a non-speaking person you
should definitely check it out do you
think it's offensive when someone who's
neurotypical plays a character that is
autistic yes that was one thing I was
Lear bring up especially where Veronica
was bringing up about the more inclusive
basically inclusive appropriation I do
feel like it's so offensive with someone
that's neurotypical to portray someone
that's autistic like see did that with
um with a little girl who was of not on
the Spectrum and she had a lot of
backlash for that and I see what they're
trying to do but they don't think about
why not someone that can understand it
especially for the fact this is
something that's not temporary this is
permanent something that's kind of
important is that in the media a lot we
see characters with autism their entire
character development is either learning
to cope with autism or learning to mask
autism uh and it's not often something
where it's like yourself where it's like
you uh your story is learning music
right and becoming a teacher and that's
such a more wholesome story than a
person who's basically uh learning to
suppress themselves yeah I was going to
I think the reason why I have such a
push back against the good doctor and
atypicals because being i' I went to
drama school I've surrounded my myself
with industry professionals who are not
autistic I know the intent and I just in
my opinion they're doing it for money
I'm sorry I just I'm sorry I just it's
selfish it's greedy and no matter even
if even if they think they're doing the
the right thing because they're relying
most of the time on stereotypes they're
push they're continuing to push the
narrative that we are not um just one
monolith and for me that really bothers
me and in no way am I shape or trying
and I totally agree with that too I I I
I think it's better than spectrum that
could be said for anything though it's
like I think I think what like the same
way about like lgbtq films with straight
guys who try to like Pander and be all
you know clearly you know they're
playing gay characters to win an Oscar I
mean I look I think of salt yeah gay for
pay yeah I think media as a whole is
superficial 90% of the time there's like
some deep movies deep shows things like
that but the reason why they only deal
with how they deal with their autism or
where they got their autism from and not
something deeper like your story is
because they don't tell those stories
they just tell you the quickest thing
they could tell you that's why I was so
honored to be on American Idol I I I am
very very happy with how they portrayed
me uh they even included my meltdown in
there as well it was it was very raw and
they didn't skew it I I can truly say
that you know so I'm I that's another
reason why I say I think we're headed in
the direct right right direction because
I'm a firsthand lived example of that
last point and then you you were talking
about how oh lgbtq films or actors of
different races and there's not that
much happening with actors without
autism um representing characters with
autism that's there that's just cuz
there's not enough movies being made
about that like you saw ca's music and
there was tons of backlash against that
but there hasn't been that much backlash
in recent films because there just
aren't enough films being made which is
ironic because CIA actually came out
last year and said that she was di she
diagnosed with autism which is a whole
other ball game that intrigues me but
anyway I just I I had to throw lot of
writing props there let's move on to the
next prompt all right it's better for
autistic people to date within the
community
you know
what you know what I might I might just
pop a squat you hesitated I'm curious if
you want to start I hesitated because I
that's such a superficial thing to look
I mean like and just and the basis of it
like I don't want to just be with
somebody just because they're autistic
but you know it's it's good to find
commonality in someone and I think
autism is a huge part of my identity and
how I see the and how we see the world
and just like I personally don't look
for I mean granted I've never been in a
relationship and I think me being
autistic and not trusting guys in
particular is something that I struggle
with but I can see how it is better
because it's easy just to because that
autistic person might be able to like
see you like like at just even sitting
here just talking about our experiences
like you can say something and I can see
you in that moment and it feels good but
ultimately I don't think it's the end
all be so Abby you want to talk about
dating David who's on the Spectrum David
my boyfriend is also on the autism
spectrum and we like to go try go go to
like the Sentry City Mall independently
sometimes and what's great about David
that he understands the way my mind
works he understands my autism and we
just went to the zoo yesterday for her
autism dating someone within the autism
Community is right and David understands
her autism just the other night we had a
big um dinner in a restaurant and there
was a crying baby right next to our
table what did David do for you he
covered my ears and then some ways that
that baby actually really liked me when
he was crying he was a lot you know who
he reminded me of Curious
George the little monkey and his mother
reminded me of the Man with the Yellow
Hat she's great with the analogies right
but but what was great is that when she
started to have a meltdown and and an
you know real anxiety attack because
that screaming baby that auditory sound
they wouldn't change tables we asked to
change our table the restaurant wouldn't
do it it was just one of those
unfortunate scenes family was really
nice it was just unfortunate David
leaned over and covered her ears and let
her experience that and I'm not sure a
typical person would get that or
understand that or have patience for
that and that happens by the way a lot
would do you feel uncomfortable having a
neurotypical person date Abby um
candidly speaking I guess I kind of
would because the Inn
um she needs an aid to help her always
we're still learning life skills I don't
understand how a typical person might be
able to have that level of patience I'm
not saying it's not possible but I just
think in general um and what I've
witnessed between David and Abby is is
like literally makes me cry tears of joy
it's the most beautiful thing
ever I've never been in a relationship
either and I 100% am would love to date
someone else on the Spectrum I I
definitely think that there would be a
lot of beautiful connection there
however there really is something
beautiful about a neurotypical person
who just gives a crap I'm personally no
less attracted to uh autistic people
than I am to neurotypical people uh but
but man I'd be lying if I said I did not
want I'd be lying if I said I did not
only want to date someone on the
Spectrum I actually do agree with y'all
was saying earlier like I do see where
y'all coming from about having someone
on the Spectrum date with someone on the
Spectrum just would lead less Pro it
will bring less problems but it just
depends on the person I guess because I
know me cuz I can relate with in I just
instead I'm pansexual and unfortunately
some people who I had feelings for I had
to try and find many reasons not to have
feelings for them especially at work
because they are because story my life I
don't yeah no cuz I just I hate it cuz
it's it's just weird inappropriate for
me but any and I just think people on a
spectrum should be able to make a choice
if it's safe to do so because we are
living in a garden of evil and we do
have we do have unfortunately people
that will manipulate those of us whether
we still have our innocence or not what
about you what's your dating life like
kid I'm kidding I'm totally kidding I'm
K so I'm
16 oh there you go um you obviously
should be aware that you know sometimes
people will pre on those who they think
they can manipulate uh even in
neurotypical relationships but at the
same time I don't think that anyone kind
of regardless of uh who they are should
close themselves off to someone sto
solely based on like a group that
they're a part of or a stereotype right
that I age with I think that we should
treat everyone as individuals and look
at as such and so maybe we should be
kind of open to uh whatever comes our
way exactly let me put it this way the
autism label should not be the reason
why a a neurotypical person would not
want to date someone on the Spectrum the
autism themselves you know you see what
I mean it's it's it's hard to explain
you know like the label can't get in the
ways if if someone is like oh by the way
I have autism and then they just
immediately walk away just because of
that you know then I think that that's a
little bit of a problem I think dating
is probably a struggle for many people
whether
and that's why I have respect for you
specially for fact you're a single mom
you Tak two kids full job like I have
total respect for cuz my mom is in a
similar boat I completely have full
respect for you so I understand
completely how did you go about I guess
setting up that blind date is there like
a way for maybe autistic people to be
able to date easier is there because she
was on Love on the Spectrum and so that
was like a random thing that came from
Australia to the US and I'll be honest
with you even saying yes to doing that
show she didn't really know what it was
I didn't really know it was but then I
saw Australia season 1 and it made me
nervous because they were driving cars
College grads they were going to Europe
by themselves and I was like well we
don't have that and there's a big
expressive language issue so I think you
want pardon the term Asbergers in love
because these folks have a different
skill set and I didn't want her to be in
over her head she didn't care really one
way or the other so obviously it was a
great thing we did but I will say that
the team once they came over was really
they were really kind about it and they
let her kind of be her and do her thing
and that's right cuz I couldn't sit I
couldn't focus and sit still I needed my
I needed to be moving during the
interview yeah yeah you made it through
with flying colors thank you and and
flying colors means victoriously by the
way and you're doing it here now yes
autism can be a
strength had to think about that huh
H I don't know I don't want I don't want
to say it's a I know people say it's a
superpower I don't agree that it's a
superpower one of the reasons why like I
write about autism appreciation with my
son um and I haven't really told the
story of Reason Why when my son was
first showing size of delay and we were
getting him diagnosed it's all I thought
about was the worst thing in the world
terrible things are going to happen
terrible things are going to happen as I
was worrying about it being the worst
thing in the world I had a heart attack
and it turns out I needed a quintuple
bypass so I had a quintuple bypass I was
35 um um I had no idea I had no health
problems before that or anything and I
remember being in the hospital and I
didn't think about what he couldn't do I
didn't think about my worries I just
wanted to see him I want to get my son
back and since that day I've seen I've
tried to focus my entire life on
positives but especially when it comes
to him the positives that come with his
autism and the fact as I said before
he's he's true he's honest he's genuine
his soul is pure the things that he does
are for a good reason and a lot of the
things that I think sometimes I'm guilty
of as somebody who's you know
neurotypical um you know selfish
Tendencies sometimes or conceit or
arrogance things like that he doesn't
have those things and it's almost like
the removal of those things are his
strength I actually agree like like I
see your point because I do think autism
is a strength as you said being autistic
it's like you have like I guess in my my
meaning double the Innocence versus how
you would be when you're typical because
when I was in high
school imagine all the crap I have
to EES drop on and I'm just like yeah I
think I know how you're going to be
growing up but it's not all of them any
anyways but the whole point though is
some of them do remind you the kind the
times where those innocence is almost so
valuable cuz you know you only want to
have them once and sometimes depend what
you do you may get it partly and some
days you may get it but not the same way
like you used to so yes I'm a personally
I'm a little on the fence about the pure
thing I was called Pure a lot uh as a
teenager I I don't I don't I just I'm
not totally sure how I feel about that
but I totally understand what you're
saying in every other way and for me it
takes the form of autism is my
superpower autism is my strength autism
is something I have it's not something
that I am um that's my Rel relationship
with it and I will accommodate your
relationships with your autism autism is
not always a strength though some of the
most traumatic moments of my life have
been sensory overloads meltdowns uh in
public so I think that that would be
kind of ridiculous to call that a
strength uh but at the same time autism
is very much a strength in so many other
ways um for me I didto
that but I will say I am slightly
different in the sense of like I
identify as an autistic person rather
than person with autism because it's not
something I need to otherize for me I
understand why other people would kind
of I they have everyone has their right
to the preference in terms of it being a
strength I see it as a strength because
frankly I don't know who I would be
without it because for me in terms of
how to incorporate my autism to that I
use it as part of my Arsenal not as like
a crutch but like just more as like a I
can do this because I
have this mixture of my autism and my
upbringing and I kind of bring them two
together because that's what I know you
can't simply look at autism as a deficit
as opposed to a strength because that's
basically saying part of who that person
is is a deficit and and that's not
correct and so it's better that we try
and have this positive outlook on it
instead of saying hey this person has a
problem it's hey this person is
different how can we help them or accept
them but see in aby's case there is a
deficit and that's the difference so
that's why the Spectrum and the language
is confusing if you have to learn to
talk and you have to learn that the
world is happening right here because
some people come in so isolated just
shut down and I wish that the industry
would change the language so that those
that have overcome deficit are honored
and those that have just a difference
are honored do you see why the language
and the confusion and new diagnostic
things it's all sort of Blurred Lines
until get this clear and it's it's to me
the biggest problem hey Abby I want to
ask you a question what do you what do
you think your strengths are my
strengths are
um singing um swimming I can see things
before anyone else I could remember
things I can hear things far away in the
distance yeah no it's very very
important that we all acknowledge the
fact that everybody whether we're on the
Spectrum or not has strengths and
weaknesses uh things that make us uh
unique um just because the weaknesses or
deficits if you will might seem a bit
more outlandish or might be things that
um an overwhelming majority of society
does not struggle with doesn't mean that
that that unique struggle is any less
valid I just want to say that it's
wonderful to get to talk to everyone and
I'm really glad to be able to hear about
all your experiences because I didn't
know a lot of like the experiences that
you guys have had I'm really glad I was
able to understand those and learn those
today so to conclude it I know you were
recently on American Idol um we would
love to hear you sing Oh well before I
sing before
I um go stream my brand new EP regroup
I've worked with some absolutely
incredible people including my drummer
Logan Shephard shout out to you man who
is also on the Spectrum and is a touring
drummer it anything is possible and uh
you are the best that will never be in
my life in my
life what about me no your turn yes I
have you know
Taylor Swift the singer oh yeah she's
great she's amazing um I where I get
older but just never wiser midnights
become my
afternoons you guys want to hug Shake It
Out used
be sing Oh you sound great Abby how's my
singing
voice whatever you want
oh totally yeah hi Vlog I'm dad